you were saying some things have changed
I gave the intro and right off the bat
the first thing you said that some
opinions have changed what has changed
oh that's a good question let's get
right into it um
specifically like when you mentioned
that I was uh against Trump
right well what you're talking about is
a video I posted also in a Jamaican
accent when Trump lost the election and
I said boss man Biden beat Trump and
whatnot
I still the reasons I was against Trump
at that time have not changed you know
the like specifically you know the
racist stuff
it's debatable you know people got their
own opinions on whether he's actually
racist but I'm talking about the
comments of like you know there's good
people on both sides when talking about
the neo-nazis that's the stuff that made
me be against Trump at the time but at
that time when Biden won the election I
was big enough Biden and my feelings of
Biden have changed
so you don't have the same this is the
most popular president we've ever had 81
million votes your opinions on him has
changed on Biden yeah yeah
in what way I mean what
does it look like this country is going
well
you know there's uh the economy is you
know absolute [ __ ] in La there's
homeless people everywhere yeah
I mean they're just doing drugs out on
the streets
we gave all that money to Ukraine for
what
we uh we our economy don't we have
enough problems to take care of within
our own country
rather than go spending all our tax
dollars giving it to some other country
while we have homelessness everywhere
it's rampant and we're giving out crack
pipes to people
yeah but isn't that an LA problem like
is that something that your boy Newsome
has to kind of clean up or Garcetti this
is also New York though that's also
Illinois though that's also you know
Portland
Seattle what Portland came out and said
yesterday did you hear about that Tyler
did you hear what the Portland guy said
yesterday we got to figure this out this
homelessness problem is is bad you know
the too many drugs out there and what
are you talking about these are the
byproducts of your policy I mean it
boggles my mind Gavin Newsom is even in
office I mean it's almost as if you had
a governor there who was his job was to
just have everything go to [ __ ] as much
as possible it's almost like that's his
objective like how can I [ __ ] up this
state as much as possible
that's what it looks like he crushed it
in the recall what was that in 2020 2021
and it wasn't even there against Larry
Elder doesn't make any sense to me that
that also goes for the mayor of La I
mean I mean it's all it's all absolute
[ __ ] yeah you know I I've grown up I've
been born and raised in La my entire
life I've never seen anything like this
when did it start really getting bad
because it didn't start during covet it
got exponentially worse during coven
as I'm sure it was like in a lot of
cities all across America
also the stuff in the vaccine I just
don't agree with I think it's morally
wrong I don't feel like people should be
forced to take anything
I think it's absolutely insane why do
you well here's the question though
should you come across as a you you have
a very different experience in life than
the average person you've seen a lot
okay in your life and at a very young
age so to you a nice car to an average
gamer oh my God that's a Lamborghini
you'd like to just I've seen the cars
you've seen this incorrect that's
incorrect you still value that you'll
still see me
this is this is like the the number one
misconception about me and my upbringing
that like I I was just you know given
Lamborghinis or that's not what I'm
saying that's right no but but still
like a Lamborghini like this is what
people don't understand is that like for
the majority of my life I've been
absolutely broke like I mean like living
paycheck to paycheck like throughout my
early 20s I mean throughout like you
know up until my late 20s
when I started when my acting career
started taking off and I was making
enough money to support myself so I
didn't have to work at nine to five yeah
I mean if I had like you know 700 in my
bank account then that was like a lot of
money
you know what I'm saying like for the
majority of my life up until my mid-20s
instead in in until I started getting
you know consistent recurring roles or
series regulars on TV shows but I guess
the point I'm trying to make and I I
appreciate you saying that I think one
part you said you know might I would
tell my dad that I need some money would
say go wash my car here 60 bucks right
so you always had to earn based on what
you said the way you were raised I
actually think you were raised the right
way by hey we have the money but this
doesn't mean me too but what I'm saying
is you've been on the Jets you've been
around the celebrity you've been on the
Hollywood people you've seen all these
guys they're regular people that come to
your house I'm assuming that's the life
you were around so you but you're also
in a space where if I'm if let's just
say I'm your you know my father's a
general of the army who am I going to be
around military guys vets Colonels
officers you know that's my world so I
understand military that's the world I
come from so my language is yes sir this
and maybe I hate it maybe it's too much
like stop cleaning my bed in the morning
I don't clean my bed there's going to be
some kind of resentment towards a
military background right you hear
something or or if my father was a
pastor of a big church and I got caught
smoking weed and the next Sunday morning
the pastor I remember being at church
when my pastor's son got caught doing
something and he had to talk about it on
stage 20 000 members not comfortable so
the pressure of being the son of a
preacher's boy we've read about it we've
you know you've seen it all over the
place where there's certain pressures
that comes with it but you know the
Bible studies you know all that's
because that's your world same with
athletes you know Michael Jordan's son
you know he's got the shadow of his
father and you know he's trying to you
know there's no way in the world you're
going to match that shadow
for you
you're in a family where the last name
is Hanks it's Tom Hanks and your mom's
also an actress and they both made it to
the top of your dad's in the goat status
he's one of the greatest of all time to
do what he's done I know he talked about
what agrees until today get some
emotional gives you emotion when you
talk about some of the movies
you know but for you to say what you
just said
about Biden what you just said about
California about Newsome comfortably the
way that you did
and then in that world most of them
support what Newsome does most of them
supported the shutdown most of them
supported the vaccine most of them
supported how do you how do you is that
a battle you deal with or no you're
pretty comfortable with your position
and hey this is who I am
I'd rather be hated for who I am Than
Love For Whom I'm not
have you always been like that
not always
but uh
as I get older I uh
I just feel that that's important
I mean I I I can't be anybody other than
who I am
you know
I could yeah you could you could be who
you are of just you could omit you know
what I'm saying I could be who I am and
just not say that you know but we're
having a discussion you know I could
just omit that but then isn't it kind of
a liable Mission if I choose not to say
something that I really believe I mean
we're on a podcast I'm with you you're
you know I already know coming into this
this is going to be an extremely
intelligent discussion this is a type of
platform for extremely intelligent
discussions I haven't mentioned this but
I mean it's such a privilege to be here
because I'm a huge fan of the podcast I
watched all the mafia States of America
like I love this [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying so this is a trip and it's dope
to be here having a conversation with
you of tremendous respect for for you
and both you guys so it's really a
privilege to be here so if this is the
platform to have a a you know
intelligent discussion like that then
why wouldn't I is it uh uh is it tough
to do that is it tough to uh I guess let
me ask the question a different way so
for example a a steinburner son let's
say everybody knows the steinburner last
name you think about what the Yankees
imagine if his son is like yeah I think
baseball's you know I think I'm not a
Yankees fan
and I'm a Red Sox fan hypothetically
that's your position that's a very
dramatic position well it's interesting
right because technically I mean
politics whether you are on the left or
the right shouldn't have anything to do
with your skill set as an actor or an
Entertainer I agree so but but somehow
it's been skewed that way somehow it has
been skewed that way where if you're an
entertainment or Hollywood then you're
only allowed to promote one side
and if you don't if you prompt the other
side at all you're like persona non
grata but at this point I mean I've
already been so [ __ ] outspoken about
anything my whole life it's like [ __ ] it
you know what I'm saying people who are
going to work with me are going to want
to work with me because I'm a talented
actor or because we have a we have a
relationship and if they don't then [ __ ]
it you know what I'm saying I I I I'm no
longer dependent on having to put all my
eggs in one basket whether it's acting
music
um or anything else I got going on
because I have something else now I have
my my myself Mastery Program my coaching
program and that's extremely fulfilling
because I get to work one-on-one with
people and uh help change their lives
you know because people have seen my
story and how I've changed my life even
though I'm still outspoken I'm sober
I got in the best shape of my life and
I'm actively pursuing something that's
benefiting people directly where I get
to work with people one-on-one and and
witness their growth and do what I can
to Aid their growth right before right
in front of my eyes because I'm not
saying I have all the answers but I but
I can say is that most of the time when
people reach out to me I know exactly
what they're going through because I've
been there so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]